the New York Giants are headlining the
news but not because they upset the
Green Bay Packers it's because of this
guy no no not Tommy cutlets this guy
that's Tommy DeVito's agent Sean
stellato Who Tommy calls the Italian
Stallion of sports agents and he
honestly is just that I mean he showed
up to the game in a black pinstriped
suit a black top hat sort of thing and a
gold bracelet on the guy is legit though
and he has clients like Alfred Morris to
prove it he was also honored by the
Boston Italian consulate and will be
inducted into the national Italian
American Sports Hall of Fame this week
was also a Star Quarterback at Salem
High School back in the day while he's
arguably a hero to the Italian-American
Community after going viral Payton and
Eli Manning sure had their fun with him
while the cameras followed everywhere he
went Dayton asked what was in the blue
bag and Eli confidently responded saying
it must be cullets honestly I wouldn't
be surprised